what's going on guys this is rob and
episode six of the boys was crazy this
was probably
this was the best episode of the series
so far i'm not even gonna lie like it
was
it was great and there was a lot of
emotion in it i'm not gonna lie about 20
minutes in i was like so when are we
going to get to herogasm
here's a real question how many of you
guys skipped to the part with herogasm
and then went back and watched the the
other parts of it later right you just
wanted to see right here what he orgasm
looked like i'm willing to bet more than
a few of you
probably did that if we're being honest
with ourselves here i did not like for
real for true i did not but i i god i
love this episode okay so obviously
let's talk about herogasm right let's
let's let's talk about that whole thing
we did a video earlier it was like we
need to talk about this youtube of
course demonetized it right pepsi
doesn't like those kinds of videos and
youtube does whatever advertisers want
so the thing about this is that uh you
know who cares about demonetization
doesn't matter to me the thing about is
that it was crazy um it wasn't as
extreme as it was in the comics to be
honest with you and i'm kind of
surprised by that you know to a degree i
mean granted i guess there's only so
much they can get away with there's only
so much they can do because if they had
done it pretty much exactly the way it
was in the comics it'd still be pretty
intense and here's a crazy thing we
still haven't seen teenage kicks yet
because that gets crazy they're
technically adults well i don't know i
don't remember if they're teenagers or
not but it's it's one of those weird
things the idea of the way they did it
basically being this byproduct that was
seemingly launched by tnt or at least it
kind of shifts from one location to the
next it doesn't seem as though it's
officially sanctioned by vaude american
that's one thing i kind of wish they'd
done because it would have shown the
levels of depravity that that vaude
american was capable of and and that
they just didn't really care about
anything they would just let superheroes
do whatever they wanted to do so long as
their bottom line gets padded but uh at
the end of the day it was i mean it was
basically an orgy with superheroes right
it lived up to its name so again you
know it wasn't the it wasn't it wasn't
everything that i thought it would be
but it for the most part gave us what we
expected to see
from that kind of thing again it's a
more realistic and tangible depiction of
that having said that the guy with the
great big uh
member
that like that guy's name so in the show
mother's milk referred to him as love
sausage and that's the name he started
calling himself that's his actual name
in the comics right he's part of the
glorious five-year plan so one of the
things to know and for the most part the
boys comic largely focuses on the united
states the only real things you get
outside the united states are like the
history of the characters so like billy
butcher which is pretty ambiguous over
the course the original comic to be on
it's over comics explained we're
covering the series dear becky which
basically gives us like it kind of gives
us the backstory so it's everything that
was going on with the boys before huey
joined when you had like mallory leading
the team and all that stuff uh so we're
covering that right now but you still
don't necessarily get the true origin of
billy butcher you kind of do but not
really the whole thing with frenchie and
his story the whole thing with mother's
milk which i'm kind of surprised they
haven't done the whole thing with
mother's milk here's okay so i don't
know if they're going to do this well
they're probably not going to because
it's the nature of them so kind of a
little bit of a spoiler here potentially
maybe i don't really know but with
mother's milk the reason why he gets
that name is because he was born with
compound v
the difference is that he has to get a
sustainable
injection so to speak of compound v the
way this works is it's basically his mom
she's just this great big huge enormous
woman
and he nurses from his mom and that's
how he gets his fix of compound v which
keeps him from just breaking down right
keeps him from basically dying it's kind
of crazy uh it's it's
i mean it was weird like when you first
saw in the comics she was just like this
job of the hut type chick and you were
just like you're like
boo boo mother's milk you know it's just
like okay this is some wild stuff but
it's just one of those things that kind
of goes into it right it's kind of kind
of crazy butch by the way at the end of
this video
just fair warning i'll let you know
before i do i'm going to do a huge dump
on black noir because i'm really curious
to see if this is the direction they're
going to go in so i'll warn you ahead of
time because they'll you know likely be
spoilers for that but with vaude
american or with the boys largely
focusing on vaude american you don't
really get a lot of what goes on
overseas however the soviet union tried
to launch their own superhero team which
was called the glorious five-year plan
love sausage was a member of that
is his
member as big in the comics as it is in
the show no
but it's still pretty huge
it's still pretty enormous but it's one
of those one of those wild things that
goes on uh with the boys comic having
said that i did love a lot of like the
emotional stuff that went into it you
know the the the whole complexity of it
all the idea that a train finally got
his revenge i i will say i love this
speech that ashley gave him right where
she's like okay so like you want to be
all pissed off about how everything
happened with your brother but how many
people have you killed how much
collateral damage have you caused and
then well now it's different because
it's you now it's different because it
affects you personally right if you
didn't care that you were hurting people
before why would you care that people
you know are getting hurt right you're
not the exception to the rule you're not
special i loved that like i love that
speech because it really just kind of it
put things into perspective right you
know like rules for thee not for me like
that kind of a thing and so it was
really intriguing in that way but i did
like that he got his revenge and
literally dragged that guy just i mean
it was nuts man he went straight up
mussolini on that guy right just drug
him through the streets
right like it was pretty brutal man but
it was cool to see to see that whole
thing go down i did like the the kind of
turn with a train you know with this
idea that he had essentially apologized
to huey and initially i thought it was
going to be one of those things where he
just kind of blows him off like i'm
sorry okay i got other stuff to focus on
but it was cool to see that he was kind
of like i genuinely feel bad for what i
did because now i actually understand
how people like you feel because now is
actually impacting me on a personal
level i did love that i i love that
whole emotional scene more so than that
though and this is the thing that we
gotta talk about we have to talk about
this the fight between homelander and
soldier boy tell me that was not one of
the best fights between two comic book
based characters that you've ever seen
that was legit that was a just
ridiculously good fight i loved it and
to be honest with you i didn't know
exactly how they were going to handle it
i didn't know if it was going to be one
of these like overly extravagant fights
like neo versus agent smith where they
take to the sky and everybody's watching
no it was just a pretty basic straight
up fight you know what it reminded me of
it reminded me of the fight between uh
roddy piper and keith david and they
live that's what it reminded me of right
like was it was it they live the movie
we're like where he's like put on the
glasses like i think it's they like him
rough top my head but like i love that
whole scene like i love that fight
between them i really love the idea that
homelander idolized soldier boy and was
like i looked up to you and i saw your
movies and like you're the reason why i
ended up doing what i was doing or at
least to a degree right then he became
corrupted by it all but you know it's
one of those things where like he looked
up to soldier boy the fight between the
two was just great it was just like a
knock down drag out bare knuckle fight i
loved it right the only the thing that i
think would have made it better and i
know this is going to sound a little
weird in the modern era the thing that i
think would have made it better is if
they had done what they did in that
fight between roddy piper and keith
david where there was no music at all it
was just a straight up fight no music no
you know ramping things up just letting
the scene play out and just removing all
that hype and drama and all that kind of
stuff it doesn't mean that it took away
from it i mean if anything it added to
it but i do think that that there are
times when just removing the music is
just a great way to add to a scene i did
love seeing billy butcher jump in there
and then i did love seeing huey jump in
there that was cool but at the end of
the day i just really kind of enjoyed
the fight between homelander and and
soldier boy because it kind of went back
and forth there were a couple times and
it was like okay so obviously homelander
is more powerful than this guy he's like
well no wait a minute maybe he's not you
know
it was that kind of a thing i really i
really dug that i also love the way they
do soldier boy is really more like he's
a captain america pastiche minus like
all the incredible fighting right i mean
he's capable but he's basically a
brawler right he's not like an expert in
multiple forms of martial arts this able
to just overpower him a homelander by
literally outmaneuvering him and things
like that i love that it was just a
straight up fight between these guys and
what was really cool was basically
watching homelander flee right
homelander basically running away after
realizing that he doesn't have what it
takes to beat those guys and the cool
thing is that the you know towards the
end of the episode when you have
homelander looking in that mirror and
just kind of musing to himself or the
very least seemingly thinking to himself
he's going more and more insane now the
one thing that i do wish we'd gotten
here that we didn't get before or at
least that we got in the comics so we
haven't necessarily seen him to this
point was basically homelander making
his move so like we talked about this in
the herogasm video that we did right
like we need to talk about herogasm but
the the big turning point in that
particular story in the comics because
it was a very very significant story is
that's when homelander basically
galvanized the superhero community and
and really just kind of brought them
together now we do have one more episode
and it's the season finale as far as i'm
aware so this is when we could
potentially get into like some spoiler
territory just by kind of talking about
this but i do want to talk about this
whole thing with black noir because i
imagine a lot of people who never read
the comics and haven't looked anything
up are really curious about this guy so
spoiler alert this may very well just
kind of you know this we're going to
talk about about black noir here so the
significance of black noir really came
to a head with the original hero gasm
story because with homelander basically
galvanizing the members of the superhero
community and saying you know what like
we don't have to work for vaude american
we can just conquer the united states
right like i mean we don't need like we
don't have to answer to anybody what are
they going to do right like we're the
ones they send in when there's no one
else that can handle it what happens
when the people they send in to solve
the problem become the problem no one
can stand in our way so literally
homelander orchestrates this just
takeover with the superheroes they
invade the white house they take out
congress they take it all out right the
whole thing comes crashing down and
that's when the when the revelation of
black noir comes into play and what you
end up finding out is that black noir
was basically a backup plan he was a
fail-safe he is
a clone of homelander essentially and
the way this works is that his entire
mission was to keep an eye on homelander
so that if things went crazy and
homelander had to be taken out black
noir could be the one to do it the
problem is that mission just never came
to fruition and because he was
programmed with that goal he was
basically given a purpose that was never
served he started going insane and so
over the course of the comic what you
end up learning is a lot of the insane
things right just the going crazy losing
his mind moments with homelander was
actually black noir that it was
basically black noir masquerading as
homelander and not everything was what
it seemed that homelander was relatively
sane but not as insane as he appeared to
be for example it was black noir that
was with billy butcher's wife it was not
actually homelanders so just things
along those lines a great big huge fight
breaks out between the two and they both
basically end up dying but it's just one
of those crazy moments and i'm curious
to see if they're actually going to do
that because right now there's
speculation kind of going both ways that
there is an original black noir that we
saw that was part of payback and even in
this episode when they talk about black
noir they reference his time on payback
so all indications seem to point to the
fact that it is the black noir from
payback the same time though when when
there was that moment where he was
pulling that uh pulling his tracking
device out of his arm it looked like he
was a white guy and it wouldn't be the
first time that vod american had come
along and taken a title that previously
belonged to somebody and gave it to a
newer person and the comics that was a
whole idea behind soldier boy soldier
boy as we knew him in the boys comic was
like i think like the third version of
the character so it's not outside the
realm of possibility that like the
original black noir because we basically
saw him right like half his face was
gone he was it looked like he was
basically a dead man right that like at
that point it's like okay we have a new
black noir now right and just no one's
the wiser of the fact that vod american
basically changed him out with someone
else everybody thinks it's the original
black noir from payback and no one
really knows the truth which is that
he's a clone of homelander and he's
there to make sure that homelander stays
in check because right now we don't know
what black noir is doing we have no idea
where he's at or what he's doing or
what's going on with him we simply just
know that like he had taken off right
seemingly and what was initially
believed at the direction of homelander
but now it's just kind of out there
right so it's a really really cool thing
that goes on but i'm excited to see
where the series goes right i'm super
hyped to see what happens here but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end let me know down in the
comments section what you guys thought
about episode six what'd you think about
herogasm especially those who read the
comic what you think about the
difference between the comic and the
show did you think the comic didn't or
did you think the show didn't go far
enough do you think it was about
comparables to the comic just done in a
different way let me know and i will
catch you all later
peace